Could I have one of
those, please?
And one of those, and one
of those, thank you.
The retina of the eye is made up
of light sensitive cells--
photoreceptors called
rods and cones.
The rods help you work out the
difference between light and
dark, whereas the cones help
you figure out what colour
that light is.
Thanks very much.
You have three different
types of cones.
One responds to blue light, one
responds to green light,
and one responds to red light.
Your brain takes all this
information from these
different receptors and more,
and mashes it all together to
give you a kind of impression
of the world.
If there's something wrong with
your red cone, then the
world looks a bit like this.
Or with your green cone,
a bit like this.
Or with the blue receptor,
We call all these conditions
colour deficiencies, commonly
known as colour blindness.
Thank you.
This condition is much
more common in men.
More than one in 20 men
have it, but less
than one in 100 women.
But why?
It's all down to your genes.
Most of our chromosomes
come in pairs.
We get one from each
of our parents.
But the x chromosome
is different.
Women have two x chromosomes,
one from their mum and one
from their dad.
Men only have one x chromosome
that they get from their mum,
and a y chromosome that they get
from their dad, which is
much shorter, and in this
demonstration, quite tasty.
The genes for colour blindness
are on the x chromosome.
If a woman has something wrong
with one of the copies of this
gene on one of her chromosomes,
then she's got
another copy on the other
chromosome to back it up.
You need two broken copies of
the gene to make a woman
colour blind.
As a man's only got one x
chromosome, if there's
something wrong with that one
gene, then he'll be colour
blind and forever at risk
of choosing the wrong
flavour of ice cream.